federal agents encountered more than a
quarter million illegal aliens at the
border last month
251 487 to be exact the highest number
ever recorded in U.S history and that is
just the number that were detected
many people are blaming Democrats who
opened the Border
some are blaming the squishes who let
the Democrats get away with it
but the Democrats are blaming the
Republicans for noticing the problem
according to one Biden Administration
official quote of course the numbers
will be higher when Republican elected
officials like Smugglers falsely
proclaim the border is open because of a
court order to lift title 42.
in other words
the border is open not because the
Democrats opened it but because the
Republicans pointed out that it's open
this is a weird sort of quantum politics
in which observing the political problem
supposedly
creates the political problem in the
first place
but the libs
make this kind of claim all the time
democrats for instance encourage men to
identify as women even though men cannot
be women and even though men who think
that they're women have all sorts of
problems depression anxiety and they
kill themselves at extremely high rates
but according to the lips
the reason that men who think they're
women are depressed and suicidal has
nothing to do with the fact that they're
not really women has nothing to do with
the the problem itself rather it only
occurs
because conservatives observe that fact
and that apparently results in
transphobia
another example poor black people in the
inner cities disproportionately do
poorly in school and then don't graduate
or they do graduate but without much of
an education and then often fail to get
good jobs and Ascend the socioeconomic
ladder and according to Libs the reason
that that group often doesn't learn very
much in school has nothing to do with
political cultural and pedagogical
failures but rather occurs because the
mean old conservatives observe that fact
which then results in racism which is
which is why the the problem perpetuates
itself now we are being told
that illegal aliens are crossing the
border not because the Democrats opened
it but because conservatives observe the
open border
but the classical mechanics version of
politics I think provides the better
explanation
the political problems exist in the real
world
and the only reason the libs want us to
stop noticing is so that we don't do
anything to stop them I'm Michael
Knowles it's the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show
my favorite comment from Friday is from
Brett who says quote I don't follow
Sports
then Michael proceeds to call a hockey
player a basketball player we appreciate
the honesty Michael I will tell you the
truth as I see it that is all I can do I
will not pretend to be something that I
am not and I sincerely did not know that
that hockey player was not a basketball
player I do know the difference between
hockey and basketball but that is pretty
much where my knowledge of those Sports
end okay when I want to know about
sports I got to call Buddies of mine who
pay attention I gotta call the crane
Brothers I gotta call David Cohn I gotta
use pure talk right now go to
puretalk.com use promo code Knowles if
one of your goals this year is to do
business with companies who share your
beliefs then you got to check out Pure
Talk Pure Talk is the antidote to woke
wireless companies it is proudly
veteran-owned employs a us-based
customer service team and absolutely
refuses to spend money on fake news
networks not to mention Pure Talk
service is fantastic they're one of the
largest networks in the country you can
get blazing fast data talk and text for
as low as thirty dollars a month that's
probably half of what you're paying
Verizon ATT or T-Mobile switch over to
Pure Talk in as little as 10 minutes
while keeping your phone and your phone
number your first month is guaranteed
risk-free try it if you're not
completely happy with the service you
will get your money back this year make
it a goal to support the companies that
support you go to Pure Talk dot com
enter promo code Knowles to save 50 off
your first month that is puretalk.com
promo code Knowles Canada w-les Pure
Talk is simply
smarter
Wireless
speaking of the Southern border uh
Congressman Dan Crenshaw has a plan for
how to deal with the problem at the
southern border and that plan involves
guns and bombs
we recently introduced aumf an
authorized use of military force against
the cartels in any other organizations
that traffic fentanyl specifically so
why now and why not why not years ago
these Mexican drug cartels have been
around for a while but the difference
now is fentanyl this is not a drug
problem this is not a war on drug
problem this is a poisoning problem
and they're killing about 80 000
Americans a year and The Mexican
government does very little to thwart
this uh and I think there should be
bipartisan efforts in Congress to pass
an authorized use of military force to
deal with them uh if anything that
simply gives our president more leverage
when trying to get the Mexican
Government to do its job and that that's
its job on on thwarting immigration
which the cartels also control and
thwarting uh fentanyl coming coming
north across our border and killing
American citizens you know these people
are a lot more like Isis than they are
the mafia
I Know Dan Crenshaw gets a lot of flack
and people think that he is too quick to
use military force or to to Advocate
using military force on the question of
the Mexican cartels at the southern
border though
in principle
does anybody object to this
plenty of people can object to sending
American dollars and weapons and troops
even to go fight the war in Ukraine
against Russia plenty of people can and
I think ought to object to to things
like that
or to adventurism in Libya and all sorts
of Wars of Empire that the US has fought
but if if the situation of the Southern
border does not call for the U.S
military
what does
we are being subject right now to what
is essentially an invasion
and have been for many decades and when
I say Invasion I'm not just talking
about mothers with their kids crossing
the border or even the economic migrants
the young men who want to come over and
get better jobs and send money back to
their families and whatever
I'm talking about the Mexican drug
cartels some of the worst people on the
face of the Earth who control 100 of
border crossings from the Mexico side
who are shipping in
tons of drugs specifically fentanyl
which is killing Americans in the worst
drug crisis we've ever had in our
nation's history which trafficks women
and girls across that border and
according to certain studies rapes 60 to
80 percent of them
according to fusion and Amnesty
International I mean these guys are just
demons
and so if the if the U.S military would
not be justified in repelling an
invasion of that sort then what what's
the point of the military
so I think in principle Dan is actually
making a very good point here there's
one caveat though I would not if I were
the president today I would not today
sign off on having the military go down
to the southern border and the reason
for that is
if if I might have them be on our side
of the border to stop people from
Crossing but I wouldn't have them go
into Mexico and actually destroy the
cartels just yet the reason I wouldn't
do that is
the the drug cartels in Mexico
constitute
a fair bit of what could be called The
Mexican government
by which I mean there's an analogous
situation in Italy for a long time in
Italy the Italian government for for
most of that nation's history has not
been the only or even necessarily the
dominant force in Italian politics there
are a couple other forces there's
obviously the church the church you know
the Vatican is right there the holy see
that's been a big force in Italian
politics and the Mafia the mafia is a
big force in Italian politics okay
there's a there's a great show that came
out fairly recently called subura about
these three powers that control Rome the
the government the church and the Mafia
the mafia is a big part of it and a
similar situation is true in Mexico the
mob plays a huge role down there and so
if you destroy the cartels if you launch
a war against the cartels you're going
to completely destabilize that country
and then what's going to happen if you
have an open border then you're just
gonna have millions more people pouring
across that border if that border is not
secure so the first thing you would have
to do
is secure the board
first thing you'd have to do is build
the wall
get the enforcement down send more
border patrol agents Deport more illegal
aliens you'd have to do all of that but
then at that point
should we use military force against the
cartels well if the drug is in the
traffic humans keep coming through yeah
I see no problem with that whatsoever
speaking of the failures of the Biden
Administration
Senator John Kennedy
Senator Foghorn Leghorn himself one of
my absolute favorite figures in all of
American politics he says that the U.S
is headed for a uh a debt ceiling
standoff and uh that we shouldn't be all
that worried about the U.S actually
defaulting on its debt and here's why
the federal government spends too much
particularly the last two years and has
too much debt
and if we don't stop it
we're going to end up in a deep
recession
um
and Google may have to lay off up to 25
members of Congress that's how bad it'll
be
I don't know who does Kennedy's writing
for him maybe he writes these lines
himself Reagan used to do this Reagan
used to have a whole Treasure Trove of
zingers just ready to go
but that's a really good one
that there are many people in our
politics who are in in bed with big Tech
and that that Google would have might
have to lay off those members of
Congress if the if the default so I I
don't think that the U.S is going to
default but but I agree with Kennedy
that one there are a lot of members of
Congress who are who are beholden to Big
tech and and two the the debt situation
has spiraled so out of control that
frankly at this point it seems almost
hopeless that's very hard to dig out of
32 trillion dollars of debt when the
debt is what roughly 100 of GDP or
something or more
speaking of being in bed with big Tech
there is an issue that I have tried to
avoid talking about because I think it's
extremely Petty and and tedious but
I feel somewhat impelled to talk about
it you know I was on the road last week
I didn't have much of an opportunity to
get involved in the high school squabble
of Stephen Crowder and and making all
sorts of claims about the daily wire
hosts and and the like uh
I I generally find a conversation about
about political commentators negotiating
contracts with media companies to be the
single most boring thing on the planet
basically like chloroform on a screen
um but I I was perfectly willing to take
the personal insinuations on the chin
even though it's not true and and but
but uh
just after I filmed my last show of the
week last week uh Stephen our friend of
many years uh lobbed an attack at Jeremy
that I that really
very very few things get me angry you
know I I'm like the least angry guy in
all of politics it's probably hampered
my career frankly and I've said on the
show before I get angry like twice a
year and I guess we started early this
year I guess we started in January
um
I was going to launch into a
succinct but comprehensive monologue on
why the allegations that have been made
about
the daily wire hosts and and the company
itself are not true manifestly not true
I was going to
um
I had a lot to say on this subject and
but actually
I I mentioned this today to Jeremy and
he said you know
just be magnanimous and let it go and
that was my instinct in the first place
and to kind of stay above The Fray and
not get involved in these squabbles I
felt that what was done to Jeremy was
very very unjust very very unjust and
I'm someone who sees behind the scenes
you know I've been around this crew for
a very long time now and but
I guess his inclination is to be even
more magnanimous than I so all of that
just to say
Jeremy boring gets a lot of flack
um that guy is
and don't tell him I said anything nice
about him you know men are not supposed
to say nice things about one another
especially buddies or you know it's not
how we really operate around here
there are very very few people in
politics who are as uh generous and
loyal and principled as Jeremy boring
and in deference to his magnanimity I
will leave it at that I'll leave it at
that
but it's important loyalty is an
important thing and integrity is an
important thing and
I'll just leave it at that okay
speaking of employment
the world economic forum
the world economic Forum which just
concluded last week in Davos Switzerland
had a panel on the future of work
and
the
the future of work
looks really Pleasant for the elites if
you ask the world economic forum
the uh the world economic Forum panel
and the future of the work week
suggested that
uh perhaps the elites need more time off
not everybody needs more time off but
the elites need more time off
there was an international study that
showed that revenues actually Rose for
companies that cut down their work week
from five days to four days
and this is true really only for the
upper class the Dutch employment
Minister karyanvan genip acknowledged
that the four day work week conversation
remains quote very much a discussion for
the upper class
uh the uh this is now a year after
virtual commutes became commonplace for
white-collar employees uh 67 percent of
these white-collar employees were able
to work from home exclusively
now this would be compared to say
teachers 48 of Educators were able to
work from home exclusively 35 of
healthcare professionals were able to
work from home exclusively
which seems kind of high to me but I
guess people do telemedicine
and then basically zero percent of
service employees are able to work from
home exclusively because they have to do
real jobs with their bodies in time and
space so that all the white collar
people can stay at home
as a technical matter I guess this makes
sense
but
as a spiritual matter this is a very
very bad idea and the reason it's a bad
idea is not because white-collar workers
who are telecommuting on their laptops
while they're in their pajamas it's not
because that is necessarily going to
diminish profits for a company or tick
down GDP for a country the reason that
this is a very bad idea is because Idle
Hands Are The Devil's Playground
the reason this is a bad idea is because
it accelerates a very bad Trend that
we've been seeing in our culture now for
years which is a trend away from
physical reality
it's a trend away from acknowledging
that that we are bodies as well as Souls
you see that particularly expressed in
transgenderism transgenderism says my
body has nothing to do with who I am I'm
purely metaphysical so I might look like
a boy but I'm really a girl
you see this in the move away from real
social contact during the the lockdowns
we weren't allowed to hug our loved ones
well that's okay we can just zoom with
them let's have zoom drinks and zoom
dinner that's obviously not as
satisfying
and because when people work from home
maybe they're more efficient in some
ways but they've got a lot of downtime
and they don't get dressed and they say
well what does it matter if I get
dressed I can wear sweatpants and socks
all day because no one really cares well
it matters because you are in part a
body and you live in time and space and
so if you treat yourself like a big just
lunk of meat then you're going to behave
like a big lunk of meat and not like a
dignified human being as you as you
should
this is especially worrisome for the
elites because the elites are extremely
decadent you know their idea of fighting
Injustice around the world is to fly to
an Alpine Swiss Resort
and go skiing for a few days and eat
fancy meals and drink fancy drinks
hobnobbing with the richest and most
powerful people on earth
okay if the decadence
is an occupational hazard for these
sorts of people and now they're saying
we need to be a little bit more decadent
well you poor little people go out there
you bring me my filet mignon you deliver
it on Uber Eats and then you go back and
you eat your bugs I don't know what
accent that is I'm not sure exactly but
I don't it's just a vague kind of
Cosmopolitan accent
it's a very bad idea everybody
especially the elites need to be
actively involved there's there's no
neutrality this is something we've
talked about on the show a lot there's
no neutrality in speech there's no
neutrality in politics there's no
neutrality in the physical world you've
always got to be doing something the
question is what are you doing are you
spending time playing with your kids are
you spending time working building up a
business are you spending time fixing up
the house or are you spending time
loafing around and you know just getting
drunk and and indulging your lusts there
was an article that showed that there
were apparently hundreds and hundreds of
high-class prostitutes who are
descending on on Davos for the
conference are you what are you doing
what are you doing
if anybody needs to remain more occupied
not less I think it is those Elites now
speaking of what the elites were eating
in Davos
there was there's one video that really
seemed to go viral from the whole world
economic Forum conference this year the
elites played it a little bit closer to
the chest you know they they did not uh
George Soros did not show up I I don't
think Bill Gates showed up they weren't
totally as wild as they often are in
their commentary with all the clips
because they know that we're sort of on
to them and we're paying more attention
but there was one clip that went viral
and this was the chairman of how do you
pronounce this company Simons is that
the name let's choose to pronounce it
that way who said that people need to
stop eating meat
and that in the future we're going to
have very different types of proteins
than meat it's a very important point
that you are addressing
um
my daughter
inspired me
and said that how can you
advocate for these serial carbon value
chains if you still eat meat
and so I stopped eating meat
now the math would say well you need to
stop eating meat 11 years to compensate
for a flight to Thailand
yes
but if a billion people stop eating meat
I tell you it has a big impact
not only does it have a big impact on
the current food system but it will also
Inspire innovation of Food Systems
and I predict that we will have proteins
not coming from
meat in the future
they will probably taste even better so
why are we trying to mimic meat if we
can have a better taste they will be
zero carbon and much healthier than the
kind of food that we eat today
so this is the main clip that's gone
viral from the world economic forum and
what's what's amazing to me is
no one has pointed out what this answer
was in reaction to
the question that I haven't really found
a clip of the the question as well uh
but I did I did get to see it as it was
happening
um because you you can stream all of
those this is one of the odd things
about the world economic Forum we think
of it as this highly secretive sort of
cabal of people they live stream most of
their events and the question that was
asked specifically referenced
eating bugs and the question that was
asked was about how we can get people to
move away from eating meat and go toward
a more vegetarian or vegan or even
uh edible insects diets and and his
answer the the CEO of this company or
chairman rather very important company
uh was
oh yes of course that's what we have to
do we need a billion people to stop
eating meat and the proteins of the
future they're not going to come from
meat they're going to they're going to
taste much better
specifically in reaction to a question
that mentions edible insects so when we
hear that the davo said it's talking
about you will eat the bugs you will
live in zipad you will owe nothing and
be happy
they mean that
they mean that even at the conference
where they were clearly trying to
downplay a lot of their more ambitious
projects that is clearly something that
they have in mind and if you if you
listen to that guy I don't think that
that guy has bad intentions I think that
guy probably has very good intentions I
think he genuinely believes that is a
virtuous thing to do
is this is the the other fact of the the
great reset and the plans of the liberal
Elites who want to remake the world
after their own image
they believe that they are doing the
right thing and their plan makes sense
if you start with the premise that there
is no God there is no soul there is no
such thing as dignity we're all just
kind of random products of evolution and
we're all going to get wiped out by the
sun monster if we don't stop living like
dignified human beings if you start with
all those premises you're going to end
up at that conclusion it's like what
always happens in logic garbage in
garbage out
speaking of skepticism of scientific
advances there's a new study just came
out you'll be shocked to hear this one
a new study shows that puberty blockers
might cause depression
so if you pump little kids full of drugs
to stop them from going through puberty
this might kind of mess them up a little
bit breaking news I know stop the
presses this is a study that was done on
animals and it found out that these
puberty blockers might have all these
problems
all all decades after doctors began to
give these puberty blockers to children
uh this this study was the first of its
kind he's an animal model to examine the
potential neurological and psychiatric
effects of the puberty blockers and they
found that that they had profound
effects of increased depression in
female mice and then a male mice
increased stress and a loss of interest
in female mice profound profound effects
all 22 years after a
doctors quacks started prescribing these
to kids
this always happens
this has happened throughout all of
history
and and you know this because of now how
we we look at
scientific procedures from the past we
look at things like lobotomies
and we say wow that's ghastly when women
seem to be a little bit hysterical and
eccentric we used to just scramble up
their brains that was that was the
consensus medical procedure from all the
fancy people in the white lab coats
before that when people had had various
ailments we would put leeches on their
body or we would cut them open a little
bit and just get some blood to come out
because we thought if you get rid of the
bad blood then they they might improve
we've had all sorts of quack procedures
for all of human history and so if You
observe that
from the perspective of History you're a
sophisticated educated person
but but in my experience it's always the
very same people who can look back at
the history of Medical Science and mock
it or be aghast at the kind of
procedures that were conducted they're
the very same people who pretend that
now we've figured everything out and
that you can't question the science
in fact I did this interview it went
viral with this medical student Bronte
remzig who's a kind of tick-tock
pro-abortion activist and
her her argument for abortion
consistently boiled down to
well the American Association of
Obstetricians says that abortion is good
so that's the science and that's why we
need to do it
I said okay well if you're just
deferring to the authority of the
scientists in the 1950s the scientific
consensus was that performing lobotomies
on hysterical women was good would you
have performed a lobotomy
if you if you were a doctor or medical
student in the 50s and that's what the
trade associations of the doctors told
you to do and this girl got to give her
credit for honesty she cut she kept
contradicting herself a little bit but
she did say yes I would have yeah I
totally would say well okay at least
you're consistent I would not have call
me crazy call me a radical I would not
have performed a lobotomy even if the
scientific consensus told me to
I gave a speech somewhat recently about
how science is fake
the only thing I really know about
science is that it has been wrong about
pretty much everything for all of human
history it just over the long course of
history it has gotten pretty much
everything wrong
and so the question is not wow gosh
maybe we need to stop these puberty
blocking drugs yeah of course we do but
what else what else are we doing right
now we were told that those mRNA
vaccines were totally safe totally
effective we very quickly found out that
they were not very effective now we're
finding out that they don't seem all
that safe either anybody with two brain
cells to rub together could have known
this at the time except for the elites
except for the scientists those were the
only ones that got fooled
so only it's how I think about uh
katanji Jackson the the Justice on the
Supreme Court who was asked during her
confirmation what is a woman she
couldn't answer it said I'm not a
biologist
katanji Jackson has two degrees from
Harvard not one but two an undergraduate
and a graduate degree
and I thought of course
of course
any random Joe on the street could tell
you what a woman is it takes two degrees
from Harvard
to not know what a woman is of course
any random Joe on the street could have
told you pumping little kids full of
drugs to stop them from going through
puberty probably wasn't going to be the
best thing we've ever done
22 years later the guys in the lab coats
realize huh maybe this isn't maybe this
isn't the best idea
we figured it all out now though
now we've figured out science right
Tech technological advances are not
always progress
they're not always good
great example of this I I tried to talk
about this over a week ago and I just
kept running out of time but I think it
fits in very well with what we're
talking about right now Anna Kendrick
the actress recently went on a podcast
to Lament The a breakup that she just
had with some guy that she was really in
love with but they never got married and
then they broke up and a very sad Tale
As Old As Time in Hollywood but it got
really really dark when Anna Kendrick
revealed that she and this guy had
actually
created embryos together that is they
conceived
babies
that they just locked away in a freezer
who now I suppose will remain in that
freezer forever
I was with someone and this was somebody
I lived with and for all intents and
purposes my husband yeah really we had
embryos together and we you know this
was my person and then about six years
in somewhere around there I remember
telling my brother when things had first
kind of gone down I'm living with a
stranger like I don't know what's
happening it wasn't just the oh I'm
losing a relationship it was that I
believed that if we broke up or you know
if he left basically it was a
confirmation that it's because I'm
impossible I'm lucky that he's even
tolerating my
okay so she's she's saying a lot of
things here that don't make sense she
said look this guy was for all intents
and purposes my husband
but he wasn't
and you were not for all intents and
purposes his wife
because you didn't have that ring and
you didn't take that vow before the
minister and the witnesses and the
public and God and because you didn't
have that marriage contract you weren't
you were his concubine you were maybe
you could have maybe even become his
common law wife if you had lived
together longer
but you were you weren't cohabitation is
not for all intents and purposes the
same thing as marriage you're missing
the essential part of marriage which is
the vow to remain together and and then
you you went further down this route of
irresponsibility or you and this guy
went down further down the threat of
your responsibility
and
techno dystopia
you
had children but you didn't quite have
children
and and the way that she says this is so
jarring it kind of sends a chill up your
back she goes yeah look I mean look we
live together you know we shared a
refrigerator
um we had the same Uber Eats account and
we had embryos you know and we had a dog
and we uh you know we we sh he sometimes
took the pillow in the middle of the
night and we um created human beings
together that we put in a freezer you
know and then we and sometimes we even
borrowed each other's cars say hold on
wait what did you just say
well I say we sometimes Bart each
other's cars no before that oh you know
I no I I said that we uh we shared the
same refrigerator no after that what was
the thing of oh we had embryos together
you had embryos together oh you had
children
well not quite
not quite because now what you can do
because of our our technological
advances is
you can
make the most consequential decision
maybe of your life certainly one of them
to have children
you can
engage in the most significant act one
of the most significant acts you can
ever engage in
while still pretending that you haven't
made that decision while still
pretending that you haven't committed
that action while remaining as modern
people are so inclined to try to remain
totally uncommitted
because we know that whenever you make a
decision
to do something
all of a sudden
you are foreclosing the other options
available when you decide to marry one
person you are simultaneously deciding
not to marry this other person or that
other person or this and and I'm not
just saying this in a in a flippant way
uh well I'm picking this one gal that
means all the other gals in the world
are off too bad I would have had fun
with them no you're you're being a
little more specific
maybe you know you're dating this woman
but you
you still have an old flame for your old
high school sweetheart I don't know or
are you still you have a crush on that
girl from whatever and you and you still
you your ex-girlfriend you and you think
about her sometimes and and you are
deciding no that person dead to be that
person dead to me that other person dead
to me I will never
fulfill that love story that I wanted to
fulfill because I am making a decision
here and two roads diverged in a yellow
wood and sorry I could not be one
traveler and travel both long I stood
and looked down one as far as it could
to where it bent in the undergrowth
and took the other as just as Fair
and having perhaps better claim because
it was grassy and wanted to wear though
as for that the passing there Lane them
equally about the same and each that
morning equally laying leaves no stress
no trodden black oh I kept the first for
another day but knowing how way leads on
to way I doubted that I should ever come
back and I shall say this with a size
somewhere ages and ages hence two roads
diverge now wouldn't I I took the One
Less Traveled by and that has made all
the difference when in fact there's no
evidence that the other road was Less
Traveled or the other one was more
traveled or anything like that you're
making a decision and you know that way
leads on to weighing you're not going to
come back to the other one and people
don't want to do that anymore
that's why that's why younger people
don't tend to stay in one career they
tend to kind of switch up their jobs and
switch up their careers that's why young
people don't get married early these
days they well we just need to meet new
people and travel and have new
experiences and this is why young people
very often don't want to have children
these days is because when you have
children you are closing off a stage of
life that you were in adolescence and
you're entering into a new stage of life
and people don't want to do this this is
why young people these days I think
remain enamored of their childhood
interests
that's why you have so many more young
people these days continuing to pursue
the same kinds of activities that they
did when they were children I I said
look I'm not a big Disney guy but I
could see an argument for why adults can
go to Disney World but the reason that
adults should go to Disney World is to
take their children there I think it's
fine for adults to play little board
games and even video games and whatever
they can do all that stuff but at a
certain point
these things that are really for
children become
weird for adults to do
unless the adults are doing it with
their children you do you actually get
this opportunity to kind of relive your
childhood and engage in all these fun
things and roll around on the ground and
wrestle and play and do I don't know
throw a ball around but if you do it
just for yourself and you pretend that
you're still a child that's going to be
grotesque if you do it in the a natural
and orderly flow of life where you make
a decision go on enter into society have
kids play around do all the stuff that
people are supposed to do then it's nice
and it's nice and it makes sense and
it's good and you're not stuck in this
grotesquery where you just you're like a
hamster spinning on a wheel you're like
a hamster that was pumped with puberty
blockers spinning on a wheel and you you
don't go into maturity and then you end
up whining on podcasts about about how
you don't seem to be going anywhere this
month
we are celebrating the anniversary
of one of the greatest moments in Daily
wire history after months of us leading
the legal battle against the federal
government and a national do not comply
campaign the Supreme Court ruled in our
favor and blocked the Biden
administration's outrageous vaccine
mandate this mandate would have set a
dangerous precedent giving the unelected
OSHA power over the personal medical
decisions of American citizens the
Supreme Court recognized this gross
paragraph and made the right decision
and we are so proud to have led the
charge in this fight but we could not
have done it without you thousands of
you joined the daily wire and over a
million Americans signed our petition
against the mandates to celebrate we are
offering 40 percent off our annual
memberships with the code do not comply
had we not won that Supreme Court case
the daily wire would have had to either
mandate the vaccine or shut down
and it's not just the daily wire this is
true of all the private companies around
the country there would not have been
some third option
because we would have been political
targets the government would have sent
its Jack booted thugs here and they
would have find us hundreds of thousands
of dollars every single day until after
not that many days we had no money left
and then they would have closed the
doors down okay so to celebrate one of
the greatest moments in Daily wire
history with 40 off your annual
membership you can go to dailywire.com
subscribe join the winning team as we
continue to crush the libs that's do not
comply for 40 off do not comply
speaking of life
there was a celebration of life for
Diamond I mentioned on the show
uh just a day or two after it happened
that diamond of diamond and silk Fame
recently died she was quite Young
gosh I think she was only 54 or
something like that and she was great I
only got to meet her I think a couple of
times I was on her show she may have
been on my show
um and I really just loved the whole act
and I thought she was really really
talented and stood up for important
things at a consequential moment in
American history and and very
courageously endorsed Donald Trump
which at the time was not really smiled
upon by the powers that be and so Trump
has come out with statements about this
lady wonderful lady and and said you
know there's going to be a celebration
of life and you should all you know say
prayers for her
Sunday January 8th 2023
the world lost an angel and true friend
Lynette diamond
Hardaway she was great
Diamond lived a life founded on her
passion and love for all of humanity
the Legacy she leaves behind will
forever remain in our hearts she was a
really great person please join us on
Saturday January 21st in Fayetteville
North Carolina she loved that state and
so do I
as we celebrate the life of diamond
she lived it in a credible way and we're
going to have a wonderful celebration
and ceremony
all of diamonds families and silk we
love silk her sister she loved her
sister so much and they loved each other
and they really loved the world
they were with me from the beginning and
they never wavered so we're going to
celebrate silk we'll be there but I'll
be there and we're going to celebrate
the life of diamond
see you in North Carolina thank you
lovely thing for Trump to do and uh
wonderful for everyone to get together
and pray for a diamond and think back on
all the good memories
the reason I mention this in particular
is because of a phrase that kept coming
up in president Trump's comments he said
celebration we're going to celebrate the
life it's a celebration of life it's a
celebration life this is how it was
reported in the news this was not a
funeral this was not awake this was a
celebration of life
and
increasingly that is what funerals are
called in our culture
you will
uh frankly now it might be even more
common than the word funeral come we're
going to have a celebration of life and
it's a little different than a funeral a
funeral that's where the body is
you're in the presence of the body if
it's an open casket wake you actually
see the body but you're releasing in the
presence of the body you say prayers
there's usually a priest uh there there
is a right and ritual to this there can
be a Requiem Mass perhaps it happens
over a series of a couple or a few days
and you go you throw flowers on the
coffin
it's lowered into the ground you bury it
and that's that
and then you lay the body to rest
celebration of life doesn't do that
celebration of life usually the body is
not present and it's just the family and
friends get together and the whole point
of it is it's supposed to be a happy
time don't be sad
the deceased person wouldn't want you to
be sad you should be happy let's get
some up upbeat music going and let's
let's get some let's be festive and
let's all be happy and I just I always
find the celebrations of life to be
trying too hard I think it's a big
mistake for people to do I know a lot of
people do it I've been to plenty of them
but I think
the funeral idea has it more correct
because death is a genuinely sad thing
and we can pretend that it's not a sad
thing we say oh well let's just
celebrate the life Let's ignore the fact
of death let's let's just focus on the
happy times but it's going to be there
you're not going to ignore that reality
kind of reminds me of what we're talking
about the top of the show Democrats want
to ignore the political realities and
they want to say no no It's Only If You
observe them that's when the problem
kicks in
don't talk about the open border because
when you when you mention the open
border that's when it's really going to
be a problem people are going to flood
over don't mention the sad fact of death
just you know as long as we all just
pretend to be happy then we'll all be
happy that's not true
it's a Jesus wept when his friend died
Jesus wept Jesus who is Incarnate to
redeem Mankind from death and give
mankind life eternal weeps when his
friend dies
moments before he raises his friend from
the dead
why does he weep it's the shortest verse
in in the gospels Jesus wept
why he we should be his death is a sad
thing it's so sad it's so tragic that
God gave His only begotten son to suffer
and die so that mankind might have
eternal life
so
it seems to me as as with so many things
in our culture
when we're we're trying to be happy by
ignoring reality when in fact the only
chance that we have of really being
happy is if we accept reality in all its
sadness in all its tragedy
and see through it and push back through
that reality you you have to first I
think in my own experience I've been to
a number of funerals and celebrations of
life you have to accept the sad fact
this person has died and death is bad
and their soul is departed and their
body is going to turn to dust
but
if you have faith in the resurrection
you say but that's not the end of the
story
and if you don't have faith in the
resurrection if you're more inclined to
these kind of secular affairs
uh again I'm not I'm not accusing
diamond and silke being secularists or I
don't I don't know their religious views
it's just it's just very common in our
culture now to engage in what is
essentially a secular Affair which is a
celebration of life if you if you just
take the secular view of things then
you can pretend that there's hope but
you don't really have hope you don't
actually you really think that is the
end of the story taking a dirt nap and
turn into worm food that really is the
end of the story
for you
and I just don't think that it is it
reminds me of a C.S Lewis quote I go
back to a lot if you look for truth you
might find comfort you might I think you
will find comfort
but if you look for the truth you might
find comfort in the end but if you look
for comfort you will find neither truth
nor comfort
you will find only soft soap and Wishful
Thinking to begin
festivities and upbeat rock music and
just focus on the good times
and in the end despair
let's not do that you have to look
reality Square in the face if you want
to have any hope
of joy and happiness
if you just if you try to ignore reality
it's not going to get you there speaking
of death
Elon Musk
says that after he got his second covid
booster shot he felt like he was dying
he said I had major side effects from my
second booster shot felt like I was
dying for several days hopefully no
permanent damage but I don't know
and my cousin who's young and in Peak
Health had a serious case of myocarditis
had to go to the hospital
uh
the reason this matters is not because
this is a novel thing I think uh
many people I know who received the
kovid shot any of the covid shots
said oh yeah I felt really bad right
after I took it or after the boosters or
yeah my uncle died right shortly
thereafter or oh so-and-so had a stroke
or so-and-so had a blood clot or so and
so whatever so that that isn't
surprising at least not to me at least
not to the people who had the number of
this whole thing from from the earliest
days
the reason it matters is because Elon
Musk is so prominent he controls the
social media website
had Elon Musk not owned Twitter and
posted that comment on Twitter in the
pre-elon Twitter days he might have been
banned for it okay
and all of this takes me back to when I
was a little kid I would see these
commercials from mesothelioma and say
have you or a loved one been diagnosed
with mesothelioma you may be entitled to
financial compensation call the law
group of Jacoby and Myers or I forget
whichever Law Group it was and you can
join a class action because
you were exposed to dangerous chemicals
and
this crops up every year there's some
some version of this on the air
and there were people who actually
believed
that with this covid shot or the series
of coveted shots
from the people who had been wrong about
everything and in some cases who had
lied about everything in the the
epidemic
that this coverage out there was rushed
through with this experimental kind of
drug treatment that there would be no
side effects whatsoever no no now we've
figured out the science
no no no now we figured there are
Eternal problems that have plagued
science and politics and Mankind since
the dawn of time
but sometime around 2019 we just figured
it all out and now they're those
questions if you can believe that
and very often it's the elites who
believe that
very often it's the people with the
fancy degrees people who have two
degrees from Harvard who believe that if
you can believe that
you can believe absolutely anything at
all and very often those people do the
rest of the show continues now I'm very
happy now that we're live totally live
again
to have the member block back you do not
want to miss it okay it's music Monday
baby we're listening to some cool fast
hip Tunes I don't even know what the
tune is yet I'll read the I'll read the
sheet The Producers left me
on the member block become a member
right now use code nulls kwles at
checkout for two months free on all
annual plans we'll see you over there
[Music]